ah bin là il y avait tout d'état de près
26 places et après on a diminué à 14
places avec le co wimille avec du gel
par tous et à la place aujourd'hui on
trouve des produits de première
nécessité des fruits des légumes du
fromage et des plats à emporter fait
maison plutôt que de subir la crise
marie chef de cuisine a su rebondir en
transformant son restaurant en épicerie
fine cette étagère là c'était toute ma
vie
touma verrerie moncel mon poivre tous à
tous qui servait pour remettre les
tables et puis c'est devenu bien ma foi
pour l'épicerie voilà le matériel tout
ce qui est là et le matériel là je les
récupère et c'est mon frère qui est
boulanger à montbéliard bon les
premières heures quand j'ai commencé à
enlever tout ce qui était du restaurant
les tables et chaises et ça a été très
dur pour moi ouais j'ai dû faire un
petit peu voilà j'étais pas bien ouverte
7 jours sur 7
c'est très souvent sa clientèle d'avant
qui vient faire ses courses
je voulais garder le contact déjà avec
les gens et je me disais que aussi au
lieu de distribuer mes plats à la porte
et que les gens appellent qui voyaient
déjà ce que je fais là ça a démarré
comme ça l'idée ça dépanne bien et puis
c'est au centre ville quand même et
c'est très bon ça a le mérite d'être
connu et puis c'est vrai que si d'autres
épicerie se développe il ya quand même
ça on fera une de plus c'est très bien
pour la ville pour aider à pérenniser sa
nouvelle activité
marie bénéficiera donc quelques temps
d'une aide aux loyers versés par la
municipalité
quoi qu'il en soit l'épicerie restera
ouverte après la crise